[Musique]
comme des guerriers reine ou mère des
nations
[Musique]
son histoire résonne en chaque femme
est-ce que vous comprenez cette
polémique alors honnêtement dans ce cas
précis dans d'autres cas peut-être dans
ce cas précis d'abord est-ce qu'on sait
réellement de quelle couleur
il y a eu des il y a eu un documentaire
de la BBC qui est passé il y a pas très
longtemps qui a été diffusé et dans ce
documentaire il y a des scientifiques en
fait qui ont retrouvé le crâne les
ossements de la sœur de Cléopâtre qui
s'appelle sino et 4 exactement et donc
les en fait la somme du crâne et des
ossements montreraient que il y ait des
origines africaines donc vraiment ça sa
sœur elle aurait aussi elle les origines
africaines et on en a déduit donc les
chercheurs de la BBC on déduit que
effectivement Cléopâtre aurait été
africaine donc de couleur noire donc
effectivement pas la même couleur que
Elizabeth Taylor à l'époque parce qu'on
connait son père avec certitude mais pas
sa mère donc de toute façon aucun
spécialiste ne pourra se prononcer
vraiment donc moi pour moi la polémique
elle fait pschit à ce moment-là
c'est formidable c'est formidable enfin
les noirs sont reconnus comme membres de
l'histoire mondiale qui avait été écrit
rare les blancs on avait décrété que
Cléopâtre était blanche Elisabeth Taylor
Marion Cotillard Monica Bellucci c'était
faux c'était faux elle a très
probablement des origines africaines
puisque sa mère aurait été complètement
la concubine la concubine du roi Olomidé
donc c'est formidable c'est formidable
enfin les noirs sont réinscrits dans
l'histoire certains disent ont réécrit
l'histoire non on écrit enfin l'histoire
alors je vais vous poser une question
volontairement provocatrice on fait un
film sur Mohamed Ali c'est musclé et on
le met blanc
donc là il y a pas de polémique
pourtant pourtant quand il y a une
polémique sur James Bond oui
non non c'est la fissure de fiction
si on lui donne la couleur qu'on veut là
c'est un personnage historique dans
votre Mohamed Ali on sait qu'il était
pas de problème effectivement sur le
bonheur effectivement sur Cléopâtre
majorité des historiens disent que c'est
les Grecs sont plutôt des Titans
enfin un documentaire comme il disait
sur sur Martin Luther King ou sur Nelson
Mandela et qu'on mettait genre du jardin
pour l'incarner ça ferait chelou bah
Cléopâtre ils étaient plutôt type
d'occasion
ça c'est la chose la plus sûre
aujourd'hui merci merci
moi je vois honnêtement là sur ce cas
précis je vois pas où il a polémique
parce que la plupart des historiens donc
parle de la dy de Ptolémée et donc des
Grecs qui étaient plutôt de type
caucasien que de type africain là c'est
l'histoire c'est comme ça donc je vois
pas pourquoi voilà comme je vous disais
si on peut avec l'exemple de d'un
documentaire sur Mandela ou Martin
Luther King on mettrait pas un acteur
blanc autre question
Omar Sy qui fait et qui fait Arsène
Lupin c'est un personnage
quand vous lisez excusez-moi quand vous
lisez le roman Arsène Lupin oui mais
c'est de la fiction
de l'enfance
ils ont un fan de lui parler en plus je
crois que c'est solidaire à lui parce
que au départ ils ont proposé le rôle et
c'était pas et c'était pas exact afin de
lui pas et lui il y a directement dit
moi je peux pas jouer du pas parce que
je suis noir vous avez fait un
personnage qui avait aussi fait
polémique il a changé donc vous voyez
que ça pose quand même problème il a
répondu à
sur
la communication
voilà fin de l'histoire sur ce sujet il
y a il y a effectivement je suis
d'accord il y a pas vraiment de
polémique parce qu'on sait pas il y a
une part de mystère par contre quand je
pense que la polémique s'inscrit aussi
dans un moment où il y a un mouvement
WoW
et où ils ont mis aussi dans un film ou
une série je sais plus Anne Bollène qui
était un personnage historique donc pas
un personnage de fiction ils ont pris
une actrice noire pour jouer Anne
Bollène et donc là bah moi ça me gêne
c'est c'est plus polémique mais là il y
a pas de pour moi il y a pas de
polémique